now we'll get into the big breaking
story from the day Fulton County sets
Trump's Bond at two hundred thousand
dollars the former president's legal
team has reportedly accepted the bond
interesting former president has
received a bond amount of eighty
thousand dollars for uh allegedly
violating their RICO Act sixty thousand
dollars for six count of criminal
conspiracy Thirty blah blah blahs 200k
you get the point
Trump may post bond as cash though
commercial Surety uh through commercial
shorty or through Fulton County Jail's
10 program per the Monday bail posting
the defendant shall not violate the laws
of the state the laws of any other state
the laws of the United States of America
or any other local laws per consent bond
order they want to lock him up
that's that's that's where they're going
towards and everybody everybody keeps
telling me like oh it can't happen oh it
can't happen and then it happens they
arrested his lawyers but here's the
bigger picture
Trump's gonna win
Trump can win I don't want to make a
hard prediction but you've got a whole
bunch of outlets now panicking over this
I love this Colin rugg says CNN warns
viewers that Donald Trump has a real
chance of winning the general election
against Joe Biden can you hear the Panic
let me uh let me play this clip from CNN
for you guys Yak University 53 of the
Fox News well look at where the santis
is and all these posts look how far back
he is he doesn't crack 20 in any of them
so in Iowa you have that 20 plus point
lead for Donald Trump that's actually
smaller than the lead we see nationally
where we see these leads of 35 40 near
50 points in this particular case
of course the primary is one thing if
Trump wins the primary can he go on and
win the general election and we've had
three polls that have come out over the
last week here and I want you to take a
look at how close this race is at this
particular Point granted the general
election is over a year away the largest
lead for Joe Biden is just three points
within the margin of error no clear
leader look at these one point one point
if you go back at where we were at this
point four years ago Joe Biden's lead
with high single digits to low double
digits this is significantly close to
them when we were four years ago so this
idea that Donald Trump can't win the
general election I want you to lose that
idea this race is very very close and
Donald Trump is pulling better right now
than basically at any point during the
entire 2025 and I got one more big piece
of news for all of you
remember that uh news story that came
out that said 12th grade males are
skewing conservative
what age is 12th grade
18 and uh what is the voting age in this
country happens to be 18. hey so how
many how many of these I'll put it this
way young Trump supporters they will
they they not all of them but Trump
supporters famously say they'll they'll
walk Barefoot over broken glass to vote
for Trump
young Democrats won't do that yeah
they'll tweet they'll get likes and then
when it comes to actual voting they'll
be like I don't actually care I just
wanna I just wanted likes on social
media I I think what you'll see here is
Trump's going to get a decent enough
boost that is being missed in the polls
among young conservative men between the
ages of 18 and 21. these polls from CNN
are missing this missing these
individuals right now they're not
pulling them yeah let's take into
consideration the polling errors in the
past skewing towards Democrat
that means Trump's probably up three or
four points then add in the the young
vote that they're probably discounting
which is probably going to vote for
Trump
I think I think Trump's on track to win
as of right now we will see there's a
lot that can change we are an eternity
away in political time but I definitely
see a clear path for Trump to win this
one and this narrative that keeps coming
out from the never trumpers who won't
stop whinging and it's so annoying that
Trump can't win just I gotta tell you
man you know with all due respect to
Bill Mitchell for coming on the culture
war and debating I had to unfollow him
right away I didn't follow him before
but I was like you know like he came
here he made his case I agree with some
of the points he made him understand I'm
gonna follow him and then after like a
couple hours I was like I have to
unfollow him because it's the most vile
and ignorant nonsense I've ever seen you
can make a really good point about
DeSantis being younger and having tacked
and succeeding while admitting his
campaign is not doing well and still
make your argument why I think he'd
probably be better in the general
Bill does not do that
so I'm just like I can't the the
anti-trumper on the on the left are
actually less vocal as it seems right
now than the than the uh anti-trump in
the in the Republican party you know I
think a lot of the anti I mean um
there's still plenty in the like the
establishment in the media I think a lot
of it has dissipated quite a bit I've
really I observe a lot of rhetoric from
you know leftist circles and a lot of
them are kind of saying you know I'm
just not gonna vote for Biden again you
know I held my nose and did it and I'm
just not gonna do it I think it might
not necessarily be a huge shift of the
youth towards like in favor of trump but
I think it's going to be a pull away
from trying to support it reminds me of
that they can't stand I can only
remember this reference vaguely but that
Simpsons episode where Abe Simpson was
trying to date that old lady and then
she was like potentially gonna date some
other guy and then in the end he was
like pick me who do you watch like I
don't want either of you know it's good
enough for me and so I feel like there's
a lot of Biden voters who are going to
be like like you said I held my nose I
vote for Biden but this time I don't
want any of them and the Trump trump
base is going to be like that works for
us don't vote Democrat that's what I'm
saying like I think that that will end
up being a larger impact than they
imagined uh although not to go on to a
totally different subject but they do
seem to be ramping up covid just in time
I honestly I'd never observed this for
myself before again I was a little a
little detached and ignorant for my most
of my life and so I've always kind of
heard that you know it's election season
something's ramping up or and it's it's
turned out to be true yeah I think until
you start following politics regularly
you think oh they just say that that's
crazy but it is a consistent pattern
that something happens and I'm not
surprised that covet is uh rearing its
ugly how it's strangely enough right now
here come the lockdowns here comes the
mail-in voting here's all the stuff oh
yeah we'll see if the lockdown stuff
actually comes into full swing there's a
couple hospitals in Upstate New York
that have brought back the mask mandates
uh Portland apparently never got rid of
all of their Mass policies nobody just
nobody cares which is actually a good
sign I wonder how many places there are
like that where all of it's still
technically there and they just but in
some ways do you think that would be a
problem because it's bad they'll say oh
no we have to enforce this it's we never
took it down and so actually you're in
violation here's a fine here whatever I
don't think so I think I feel like you
do need to see it through like we should
repeal all the mess up it's good that
we're ignoring it but we should
completely we need to find out where it
is and like Advocate to you know
get it get down yeah I guess I can talk
about the word for it
um
let me show you this tweet well we have
a little Gap here uh Michael Tracy
tweeted
it's silly it's silly to declare as
foreordained truth that Trump can't win
when the official losing margin in 2020
was 42 918 votes in three states Trump
actually outperformed polls in 2020 to a
greater extent than 2016 and Biden's
support is 2024 in 2024 is much likely
to shrink than grow he's completely
correct this guy doesn't like Trump not
Trump supporter but he's right
Trump barely won in 2016. now the Trump
supporters like to say no it was
electoral major electoral Victory he was
he tons of votes no no it was something
like 70 000 what was it like 80 000
votes or something in three states in
2020 he only lost by 42 918 in three
states Trump does not need to recover
that many more votes when you look at
how bad Biden is doing Afghanistan
really screwed over by freaked everybody
out and now where the economy is at yeah
I just I I don't I'm not saying people
are going to vote for Trump they're
going to be like I voted for Biden that
was a mistake I'm voting Trump but if
Trump gets the same 75 million votes he
wins yeah they don't have the lockdowns
anymore and there's gonna be a lot of
apathetic voters who are like I just
don't care anymore yeah and I think
there are a lot of um mainstream
institutions that are aware of this the
other day when it was the anniversary of
the inflation reduction act I felt like
NPR talked about nothing but because
they're trying so desperately to say
this has been a good presidency good
things have happened we've passed great
policies please stop questioning us
please stop doubting us and it's just
not there if you have to have a
full-fledged radio campaign all day long
then obviously I don't think it's
speaking for yourself right things it's
about to stay safe no no go ahead no it
speaks for itself though if you have to
sit there and be like no look no look it
should just be pretty apparent you know
when I was making more money than I ever
had in my life and then Trump did his
like tax cuts where it affected my
bottom line you know I noticed that
immediately it was great that was the
only thing I had friends who identify as
like you know very left liberal be like
well I guess this is good I got this
extra money from Trump so and then they
never talked about it again and you love
how they personified it as you know it
was a cut for like Millionaires and
billionaires like no that that was
something for everyone but they just got
more of their own money to take home and
I was at the point in time I still had
TDS so that was kind of did you can I
ask who you voted for in 2020 did you
vote for Biden oh in 2020 no I voted for
Trump okay so in 2016 I uh voted for
Bernie in the primary area and then I
voted for nobody oh yeah because that's
interesting I think there will be a lot
of people who just will be like I can't
vote for Trump but I don't want to vote
for Biden I'm staying home well I think
that I think that's going to happen
quite a bit here and I think that at the
end of the day for the most part people
are going to vote for whoever is the
Republican nominee but I think on the on
the left you're going to see more people
deviating to a third party candidate so
right I think I think something we can
work with that yes definitely I think
something that gives me pause at least
lately if we've had James klug on the
show before and he works with Lisa
Reynolds right now he has been
interviewing people on the Santa Monica
boardwalk and the attitude in 2020 was
very much anti-trump the attitude in
2020 is very much anti-jobiden generally
speaking not as much like oh I'm gonna
go and vote to get back at Trump but
like I'm I can't do this anymore like
this is this is cutting into my bottom
lines because of my life you know my
business was shut down and I'm not going
to go over this it's been the point
where people are like openly saying like
yeah I'm gonna vote for Trump on the
Santa Monica Boardwalk like that didn't
used to be a thing it is now so I feel
like you're right like a lot of people
are just gonna not they don't have like
that drive they've been at home they've
been working and so they don't have the
drives to go and about you know actually
gonna do that like they did in 2020 when
I was just like well then you can think
about you know so I think it I think
what we have I just as it just to be my
own two cents I think we will be able to
do a lot better just because people are
not driven to go and vote right now I
think that people really were paying
attention a lot more to the mainstream
media in 2020 which they were able to
capitalize on too because covid you know
everyone they I mean they were putting
up death tolls like football scores or
and people were absolutely captivated by
that they could not look away and they
were locked in their homes in a lot of
instances so they became like I mean we
saw the absolute Insanity surrounding uh
not Chris Coleman Governor Cuomo and you
know I'm a cuomosexual people were just
but they were going absolutely now that
you've said that yeah they can clip it
and they will put it on the internet for
you oh well great well the lights always
you gotta be careful when you're quoting
oh no I mean I've been I've been through
worse it'll be all right but but people
absolutely losing their minds and
talking about how they had you know uh
crushes on Anderson Cooper and and
Governor Cuomo and because everyone was
just in there what were the Q-tips oh
yeah oh my God the swap brothers are the
giant Q-tips and then my favorite was
when the nurses were dancing on the
graves of the covet dead yes remember
that oh yeah my first one Andrew Cuomo
did a bunch of press conferences and he
wore a polo and you could see his nipple
piercings that was such a fun covered
moment jeez what a crazy time we all
lived yes look it up there are screams
I'm not gonna do that but a corporate
press got really mad at me when I said
the nurses were dancing on the graves of
the covet dead because because I think
that strikes straight through it was an
arrow right through their chain mail
just ripped right through it found that
point of entry right right in but it's
that Meme of uh the Knight with the thin
you know he's got the thin strip in his
helmet and the arrow right into it
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time